This is a special bonus episode of the 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker. I'm Roman Mars. So a few weeks back, Elliot and I held our final Power Broker event. It was an AMA on our Discord server where we shared our final thoughts about the book and our thoughts about this whole experience. We took questions from listeners. It was a ton of fun. But we know a lot of you couldn't make it. So as promised, here is a recording of the event.
这是《99% Invisible》关于《权力掮客》解析节目的特别加更集。我是罗曼·马尔斯。几周前，埃利奥特和我举办了最后一场《权力掮客》活动。那是在我们的 Discord 服务器上进行的一场 AMA（问答）活动，我们分享了对这本书的最终感想以及对整个经历的看法。我们回答了听众的问题，过程非常有趣。但我们知道很多人没能参加，所以正如承诺的那样，这是活动的录音。
One of the questions that we want to start with was just about like our impressions of the book. We've each read it three times. And so Elliot, now that you've read it three times, what is your favorite part of Power Broker? Now that I've read it three times, and now that I'm back on my mic after telling a six year old, no, he cannot play Xbox right now.
我们想从一个问题开始，就是关于我们对这本书的印象。我们每人都读了三遍。所以埃利奥特，既然你已经读了三遍，你最喜欢《权力掮客》的哪一部分？现在我已经读了三遍，而且在告诉一个六岁的孩子“不，他现在不能玩 Xbox”之后，我又回到了麦克风前。
Uh, which is why Mike was turned off briefly. Uh, I think my favorite part, I don't know, like I love that, that Al Smith biography section so much. Yeah. Just going through his, his life. It's so, it's so exciting. It's a story that until I read the Power Broker, I was really, truly unaware of, of like just what, what an amazing personality and amazing history that guy had.
呃，这就是为什么麦克风刚才关了一会儿。呃，我想我最喜欢的部分，我不知道，我非常喜欢关于阿尔·史密斯的传记部分。是的。回顾他的一生。太令人兴奋了。在读《权力掮客》之前，我真的完全不知道那个人有着多么惊人的个性和历史。
But reading it this third time through, I feel like there were parts of it I was picking up on before that I hadn't before. And I think it's any time when Robert Caro's personal kind of like feelings and interests come through, not just the part where he's writing in italics, you know, they could have done it better. You know, this was the wrong choice. But instead, how clearly he feels an admiration for some of the characters in the book and how clearly he does not feel admiration for some of the other people. But like, I don't think I fully picked up on the dislike of John Lindsay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was very funny to me on the third time through.
但第三次阅读时，我觉得我捕捉到了一些以前没注意到的部分。我认为，每当罗伯特·卡罗个人的感受和兴趣流露出来时，不仅仅是他用斜体字写的部分，你知道，“他们本可以做得更好”，你知道，“这是个错误的选择”。相反，他对他书中某些人物的钦佩之情，以及他对另一些人的厌恶之情，表现得非常清晰。但我认为我并没有完全领会他对约翰·林赛的厌恶。是的，是的，是的。第三次读的时候，我觉得这非常有趣。
But what about you, Roman? Are there parts, after this multiple readings, what are your favorite parts now? I think the end is more fun for me than previous. And I think mainly has to do with my state of mind when I was reading it. Because you're like, I've read this book three times now, finally at the end.
那你呢，罗曼？在多次阅读之后，你现在最喜欢的部分是什么？我觉得结尾对我来说比以前更有趣了。我想这主要与我阅读时的心态有关。因为你会想，“我已经读了三遍了，终于读到结尾了”。
No, actually almost the opposite. Whereas when I'd read it the first time, I was really like ready for it to be over. Like I just like making progress. And so I didn't sort of really take a lot of pleasure in the different young reporters who are taking them on, the Lindsay part, you know, like I was just looking for plot details of his fall and not sort of relishing the details of it
不，实际上恰恰相反。第一次读的时候，我真的很想快点读完。我只是喜欢取得进展。所以我并没有真正从那些挑战他的年轻记者身上，或者林赛的部分中获得太多乐趣，你知道，我只是在寻找他垮台的情节细节，而不是在细细品味其中的细节。
And so I think I've had more fun with that part in in this read and in our discussion like I I don't know if I fully even put together all the details of The Rockefeller, you know deal and stuff like that Like I just kind of read it too quickly and so that sort of phase of the fall, when you can see that the end is almost coming and you really just from your sense of accomplishment, not because you're bored, but just,
所以我认为在这次阅读和我们的讨论中，我对那部分有了更多的乐趣。我不知道我是否完全理清了洛克菲勒交易之类的所有细节。我只是读得太快了，所以当那种垮台的阶段到来，当你看到结局即将到来，而你真的只是出于成就感，而不是因为无聊，只是，
you just want to keep going. I think I breezed through that part and didn't have as much fun with it. But this time that really stood out to me more. I probably had a similar reaction, but that was so mixed in with my melancholy about us getting towards the end of the book. It was mixed with this feeling of like,
你只是想继续读下去。我想我匆匆读过了那部分，并没有从中获得太多乐趣。但这一次，那部分真的让我印象深刻。我可能有类似的反应，但这与我们即将读完这本书的忧郁感交织在一起。它混合着一种感觉，就像，
oh, I can't believe we're, Rockefeller's almost accepted his resignation. Yeah, I did feel, I had so much fun doing this in general, just like working with you, Elliot and Isabelle, and everyone's reaction to the book and really taking it on. It was just, it was so much fun. When we had our final production meeting today,
哦，我不敢相信我们，洛克菲勒几乎接受了他的辞职。是的，我确实感觉到了，做这件事本身非常有趣，就像和你、埃利奥特、伊莎贝尔以及每个人对这本书的反应和真正投入其中一样。这真的太有趣了。当我们今天开最后一次制作会议时，
I was like sad. I was like, you know, we should just like get together and like hang out. So, I mean, we have talked about doing, potential of doing other books and other projects. We haven't sort of solidified that stuff, but everyone is very, very busy with lots of other things. And so we want to be respectful of that
我感到很难过。我说，你知道，我们应该聚在一起，像朋友一样相处。所以，我的意思是，我们确实讨论过做其他书和项目的可能性。我们还没有确定下来，但每个人都忙于其他很多事情。所以我们想尊重这一点，
and make sure that we're doing a good job and make sure that this is still fun. So we will see about that, just to anticipate other questions coming up about that. Another highlight of the series is, we didn't know when we started that we were gonna talk to Robert Carrow or that he would want us to do this exactly.
并确保我们做得很好，确保这仍然很有趣。所以我们会拭目以待，预先回答关于这方面的其他问题。该系列的另一个亮点是，我们开始时并不知道我们会采访罗伯特·卡罗，或者他是否会希望我们这样做。
I thought he was gonna tell us no. I was really worried that we would have a Robert Moses relationship that he, I was worried it would be like his relationship with Moses. It was like, do not wish to be apart, do not authorize, don't do this. Like I was worried that that would be the reaction. And it's been, it's hard to describe how gratifying
我以为他会拒绝我们。我真的很担心我们会有一种罗伯特·摩西式的关系，他会像对待摩西那样。就像是，“不要想分开，不要授权，不要这样做”。我担心会是那种反应。而且，很难描述这有多么令人欣慰，
it's been to been able to speak to him multiple times and to have him engage with us about our thoughts about this book that he's been talking to people about for 50 years now. It was, I've talked about this before, about when we did our live event with him, which was an amazing dream come true. On the flight over to do it, I was writing scripts
能够多次与他交谈，并让他参与我们对这本书的思考，他已经和人们谈论了 50 年了。这，我以前谈过，关于我们和他一起举办现场活动的时候，那是一个令人惊叹的梦想成真。在飞去参加活动的飞机上，我正在为我为竞争对手网络制作的那个益智喜剧播客写剧本，我在这里就不提了。但我当时想，我不敢相信我正在写这些荒谬愚蠢的笑话。我要去和罗伯特·卡罗交谈了。真是梦想成真。但我知道罗曼，你发现自己真的很失望，为什么我……你发现这是一次非常痛苦的经历。
for this puzzle comedy podcast that I do for a competing network that I won't bring it up here. But I was like, I can't believe I'm writing these ridiculous dumb jokes. I'm gonna go talk to Robert Caro. What a dream come true thing. But I know Roman, you found yourself really underwhelmed why I'm in you and you found it a really bitter experience.
我只是在讽刺。我只是在开玩笑。非常相似。我很高兴他愿意这样做。然后当他表现得如此深思熟虑、坦率且充满情感时，那时我就想，哦天哪，这太可爱了。你知道，这让我，是的，这，
I'm just being sarcastic. I'm just facetious. Very similarly. I was so delighted that he wanted to do it. And then when he was so thoughtful and like forthright and sort of like emotional about it, that was when I was like, oh my goodness, this is so lovely. You know, it just made me so, yeah, it just,
这让我非常开心。然后，你知道，有趣的部分是和他谈论他对长岛委员会不同投票结果的记忆。你会说，“抱歉，已经过去很久了。我不太记得了。”然后他就能准确地说出来。
it made me so happy. And then, you know then the fun part was talking to him and his recall about just like the breakdown of different votes on the Long Island committee. You're like, pardon me, it's been a long time. I don't quite remember it. And then he'd know it. Exactly.
所以，是的，这真的很特别。我有点担心他会说，“我已经写过其他书了，我还要再谈这个吗？”我认为看到他从中感受到的自豪感，以及他和伊娜为了写这本书所经历的磨难，它们在他心中依然如此鲜活。这对我来说非常感人，看到这本书仍然是一种鲜活的体验，这非常特别，你知道，对他来说也有很多意义。我觉得作为一个漫画和科幻小说迷，
And so, yeah, it was really, really something. I was a little worried that he would be like, I've written other books, like, am I talking about this again? And I think it was to see the, that the pride he feels in it, and also the trials he went through to that he and Ina both went through to write it, that they're still so alive in him. It was very moving to me and very special to see that like, oh, this book is still a living kind of like experience, you know, there's so much to him as well. I feel like being a comic book and science fiction fan,
我有过这样的经历：我将自己投入到一件艺术作品中，然后见到作者、阅读或观看他们的采访，却发现他们说，“是的，我不知道，随便吧，我随手写的，谁在乎呢？”然后我就想，“哦，这对我很重要。”所以看到这对卡罗来说仍然意义重大，真的非常触动我，你知道，
I've had the experience of really investing a lot of myself into a work of art and then either meeting or reading or seeing an interview with the author and having them be like, yeah, I don't know, whatever, I tossed that off, who cares? And being like, oh, it meant a lot to me. And so to see that this still means so much to Kara was really, really touched me, you know,
这非常有意义。是的，是的，是的，我同意。我们在节目中还有很多其他嘉宾，我对此感到非常惊讶，有多少人想参与进来，比如，非常著名的人，像 AOC 和皮特·布蒂吉格等等。你有其他嘉宾带来的最喜欢的时刻吗？
it was very meaningful. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I agree. And we had a bunch of other guests on the show and I was kind of amazed by that, like how many people wanted to be involved, like, you know, very notable people, like AOC and Pete Buttigieg and stuff. Did you have a favorite moment from other guests?
我的，我的意思是，这有点自私。我想对他们所有人来说，我最喜欢的时刻是，当我们邀请 AOC 时，她思考和表达思想的方式给我留下了深刻的印象。我当时想，我要在这场采访中让她笑，我要试一试。我讲了个笑话，她说，
My, I mean, this is self-serving. My favorite moment, I think, for all of them was, when we had AOC on, I was just so impressed with the way she was thinking and articulating her thoughts through it. And I was like, I'm gonna make her laugh in this interview, I'm gonna try. And I told the joke about, she was saying
所有这些人聚在一起试图推翻罗伯特·摩西的工作，我说，所以从某种意义上说，他是一个英雄。她对此笑了，我没有从她那里得到冷眼，我非常，那是我的胜利时刻，我会随身携带。然后还有和迈克·舒尔交谈，让他说“我喜欢这本书”，然后和真正喜欢它，甚至思考得更多的人交谈。在某个时刻，我在脑子里想，好吧，他应该来做这个播客。我在做什么？
that all these people have come together to try to undo Robert Moses work and I was like so in a way he's a hero Together and that she laughed at that and that I didn't get a scowl from her like I was very I was very that was my Victory moment I'll take with me then also talking to Mike sure and having him and being like I love this book and then talk to Someone who like really loves it even, or thinks about it even more. And at a certain point in my head, I'm like, well, he should be doing this podcast. What am I doing?
他是另一个人，对一本他没有写的书有着疯狂的记忆力。他只是通过阅读就记住了。是的，我真的很喜欢和他交谈，他完全拥抱这些材料真的很棒。我，你知道，对于这些采访……你还有什么其他亮点吗？好吧，对于这些采访，我实际上对我们的嘉宾做了很多阅读，所以我通常会读他们写过的任何书或他们做过的其他事情。对于 AOC，我有，你知道她有一种，嗯，有一本关于她的传记，一种关于她早年生活和不同事情的汇编，
He was another person who had just like insane recall for a book that he did not write. He just knew it from reading it. Yeah, I really loved talking with him, and just his full embrace of the material is really great. I you know for these interviews... What other highlights did you have? Well for these interviews I do a lot of reading on our guests actually so I usually read whatever book they've written or other things that they've done. And with AOC I had you know she has a kind of um there was a biography like a sort of compilation
传记。我最喜欢的是阅读那些早期的东西，并被提醒她在开始时是如何推动变革的，以及她谈论在今天所处位置的现实政治，并将此与《权力掮客》联系起来，我当时想，
biography written about her, of her early days and different stuff. And what I had most fun with was like, reading that early stuff and being reminded of how she was exacting change in the beginning and her talking about the real politic of being in the position that she's in today and relating that to the power broker was just like, I was like,
这是一个跨时代的人才。我只是被她惊艳到了。那种将她开始的地方和她现在所处的地方并置的时刻真是不可思议。她一直很有才华和吸引力，但看到这一点并意识到，哦，我们只是她人生的开始，我认为这对世界来说是一件非常好的事情。我认为你问我这件事说明了很多问题，我最难忘的事情是我说的话，而你的回答是嘉宾正在做的事情。
this is a generational talent. I was just kind of amazed by her. That was just an incredible moment to sort of have that juxtaposition of where she started and where she is. She was always talented and engaging, but just seeing that and realizing, oh, we're just the beginning of her and our lives, which is a very good thing, I think, for the world. I think it speaks volumes that you asked me, and my thing that I was most memorable was something I said, and your answer was something the guest was doing.
我认为这充分说明了我们，我们所做的工作，我们如何看待世界。是的，是的。然后，我不知道，这种范围让我玩得很开心。很多人都在说他们喜欢我们和布伦南·李·穆里根的谈话，我们如何看待世界。是的，是的。然后，我不知道，这种范围让我玩得很开心。就像很多人都在说他们喜欢我们和布伦南·李·穆里根的谈话，这
I think that just speaks a lot about us, the work we do, how we see the world. Yeah, yeah. And then, I don't know, it was just the range of it that I had so much fun. A lot of people are chiming in that they loved us talking to Brennan Lee Mulligan, how we see the world. Yeah, yeah. And then, I don't know, it was just the range of it that I had so much fun. Like a lot of people are chiming in that they loved us talking to Brennan Lee Mulligan, which
是我孩子迄今为止最喜欢的嘉宾。他真的很有趣。还有皮特·布蒂吉格，我一直很钦佩他。听他说话非常有趣，非常有趣。我真的很喜欢，这是一段美好的时光。你知道，就像，每个人都迎接了挑战，玩得很开心。而且你知道，当我们和克拉拉·杰弗里接近尾声时，
was my kid's favorite guest by far. And he was really fun. And Pete Buttigieg, I've admired him forever. And he's so much fun, so much fun to listen to. I really, it was a great time. You know, like it was, everyone sort of came to the challenge of it and had a good time. And you know, by the time we were getting to the end with like Clara Jeffrey,
我想我们正在进行一场真正的讨论，关于你知道，新闻在当下意味着什么。你知道，她第一次以那种方式问我们问题。那真的很有趣。我不知道，这太棒了。还有柯南和大卫·西姆斯。
I think we were having a real discussion about the idea of, you know, what journalism means in the moment. And you know, she kind of asked us questions for the first time in that way. And that was kind of fun. I don't know, it was just great. And Conan and David Sims.
我的意思是，我，你知道，贾梅尔太有趣了。就像，我们，特别是早期的嘉宾，我们邀请他们来参加解析部分。这对贾梅尔和大卫·西姆斯来说是一个非常艰巨的任务。要消化的材料相对较快，而且不像我们那样投入，因为我们一直致力于通读这本书。但他们是合作者。有他们在真是太好了。他们做到了。完全是。我记得你说过，“让我们对嘉宾宽容一点。不要让他们做所有这些阅读。”好吧，
I mean, I had, you know, Jamel was so fun. Like, it was like, we, especially the early guests, we had brought them on for the, for the breakdown portion. And it was a really tall order for like Jamel and David Sims to do that. It's a lot of material to digest relatively quickly and to not be as in it as we were because we were dedicated to going through the book the whole time. But they were Coopers. It was great to have them. They pulled it off. Totally. I remember you were like, let's be a little easier on our guests. Let's not make them do all this reading. Well,
第一个是 AOC，她是第一个我们没有那样做的嘉宾，那只是因为我们没有和她有三个小时的时间。在那之后，我们想，如果他们不必评论书中的每个方面，这对他们来说会容易得多。我在纽约遇到了大卫·西姆斯，他说，“好吧，告诉我实话。是因为我表现得太差了吗？”我说，“绝对不是，大卫。”
the first one was AOC was the first one we didn't do that with and it was just because we didn't have three hours with her. And then after that happened, we were like, this is a lot easier for them if they don't have to comment on every aspect of the book in this section. And I ran into David Sims in New York, and he was like, OK, tell me the truth. Was it because I was so bad? And I was like, absolutely not, David.
你表现得很棒。那是大卫式的思考方式。我们只是让其他人更容易一些。他真的很棒。我真的，我的意思是，如果有人想来做这件事，我想我们可能想在飞行中调整它。但它只是，它只是，我们最终对他们和他们对它的看法有了更多的，
You were great. That's a very David way to think about it. We were just making it easier on the other folks. He was really great. I really, I mean, if there was somebody who would have wanted to come on to do that, I think we might have like to adjust it on the fly. But it just was, it was, and we ended up having sort of more
论文，而不是让他们评论，你知道，比如 1920 年代的镍币大亨，你知道。所以，让我们看看。我不知道，在进入更多听众的问题之前，还有什么其他想法吗？我们有——在进入其他人之前，我确实想说一件事，
of a thesis about them and their take on it versus them commenting on, you know, like nickel barons from the 1920s, you know. So, let's see. I don't know, any other thoughts before we get into some more questions from folks? We have- Something I do wanna say before we get into other people
我以前说过，我会再说一遍，我可能在最后还会再说一遍。我怎么说都不为过，罗曼，当你第一次问我是否参与其中时，这对我来说是多么令人高兴和兴奋的事情，你知道，在那之前我已经做了很多年的《99% Invisible》听众了。现在我做完了，我不参与了。
is that I've said it before, I'll say it again, I'll probably say it again at the end. I can't say enough, what a delight and an exciting thing it was for me, Roman, when you first asked me to be involved in this at all, you know, I had been a listener of 99% Invisible for many years by that point. And now I'm done with it, I don't participate.
不，我说我仍然经常听它。有时机会会打开，去做一些你以前没有真正考虑过的事情，但一旦邀请在那里，你就会意识到，哦，这是我比我能想象的任何事情都更想做的事情。然后这段经历不负你的期望。所以和你一起做这件事，和伊莎贝尔、凯西一起工作，能够和我们交谈的人交谈，真正花时间去参与、思考和沉浸在这本书中。这是我前 10 名的创作经历，甚至可能是前 5 名，但我还有很多光明的未来。还有很多年，
No, I said I still listen to it regularly. And there are some times when an opportunity kind of opens up to do something that you had not really considered doing, but once the invitation is there, you realize, oh, this is the thing I want to do more than anything else I can imagine. And then the experience lives up to your hopes about it. And so working with you on this, working with Isabelle, with Kathy, and being able to talk to the people we talk to and really take this time to engage and think about and luxuriate in this book. It's a top 10 creative experience for me, maybe even top five, but I've got a lot of light left. There's still a number of years left,
所以我不想在排名中把它定死。这很公平。这很公平。我的意思是，同样，我的意思是，最初，我和你谈论这件事是因为我长期以来一直是《Flophouse》的听众。我知道你总结这些事情的方式有些特别，但这对我来说很有趣，
so I want to leave some wiggle room for it in the rankings. That's fair. That's fair. I mean, likewise, I mean, initially, I was talking to you about it because I have been a Flophouse listener for a long time. And the way I knew that there was something in the way that you were summarizing these things, but it was entertaining to me,
尽管我很少看《Flophouse》电影。所以我当时想，让它奏效的秘诀是什么？因为在我最初的构思中，我会做更多针对这本书新手的解析。那是第一种，那是我的第一个想法。并不是我们俩对这本书都有平等的了解。
even though I rarely watch the Flophouse movies. So I was like, what is the secret to making this work? Because in my initial conception of the piece, I would do much more of the breaking down to a person new to the book. That was the first kind of, that's my first idea. And it wasn't that we both had, you know, kind of equal grounding in the book.
你说了一些非常聪明的话，你说，“如果我有 18 个要点，那么我就做了足够的总结，或者说对它做了足够的调整。”我知道我已经思考得足够多了，可以穿过，在这种情况下穿过电影，穿过总结。我喜欢当有人能把某件事归结为
And you'd said something so smart, you were like, if I have 18 bullet points, then I've done enough summarizing, or like enough adjusting to that. I know I've thought about it enough to move through the, move through the movie in this case, move through the summary. And I love it when somebody can boil something down
一个他们一直在做的数字。而且，感觉就像，哦，我不知道。我感觉到它时我就知道了。但我喜欢人们说，“不，18。”你知道，所以。20 个太多了。虽然我觉得我给了你一个真正的诱饵，因为当我做这些总结时，
to a number that they've been doing. And like, it feels like, oh, I don't know. I know it when I feel it kind of thing. But I love it when people go, no, 18. You know, like so. 20 is too much. Although I feel like I gave you a real bait and switch because then when I did these summers,
我说，“我要在这些方面写得很长。”我并没有把它们归结得那么好。但关于这一点要说的话比我曾经看过的任何《Flophouse》电影要说的多得多。完全是。但后来当它转变时，我想，哦不，但这只是有道理。也许我应该重新构思一下。我不敢相信它结果这么好。而且我也不敢相信，如果不是我们俩，你真正地解析它，
I was like, I'm gonna go long on these ones. And I did not do as good a job of boiling them down. But there's so much more to say about this than there is that I wanted to say about any movie we've ever watched with Fluff House ever. Totally. But then when it shifted and I thought, oh no, but this just makes sense. Maybe I should reconceive this. I can't believe how well it turned out. And I also can't believe how I think it would have been bad had it worked out the other way if it wasn't the two of us and you really breaking it down
我们一起努力，我想如果以另一种方式进行会很糟糕。我非常感谢你说了“是”，并且有时间去做。我的意思是，这有点像，你说，“你想余生只吃炸鸡吗？”然后我说“是”，然后你说，“我不敢相信你真的做了。”
and us sort of working on it together. I'm just so grateful that you said yes and you had time to do it. I mean, that's a little bit like, you were like, do you wanna eat nothing but fried chicken for the rest of your life? And then I say yes, and you're like, I can't believe you did it.
就像，没可能，我怎么能拒绝呢？但无论如何，这只是，它就像非常有趣，然后有趣的部分是观众的激活，你知道，让人们对此感到兴奋，他们只是每个人都立刻明白了，从嘉宾到罗伯特·卡罗，我不知道，只是每个人都，你知道，当你在一个节目中时，你知道我制作了近 15 年的《99% Invisible》，而且。是的，你是一个播客新手，但这没关系。你知道，第 12 季即将迎来 18 周年纪念，
Like, there's no way, how could I say no to it? But anyway, it was just, it's like so much fun fun and then the other part of it that was fun was like the activation of the audience and you know, like having people be excited about it and they just got everyone sort of got it right away like from the guests Robert Caro I don't know just everyone sort of you know, like when you're in a show you you know I made 99% of visible for close to 15 years and. Yeah, you're kind of a podcast newbie, but that's okay. You know, 12th House is approaching its 18th anniversary,
但你知道，那是一个多元化的行业，是的，当然。那是对的。但很少有，《时代》杂志之类的在 15 年后把你拉出来说，你知道年度最佳播客是什么吗？《900% Invisible》的《权力掮客》。他们不——这个我们已经习惯了，是的。
but you know, it's a diverse racket up there, yeah, sure. That's right. But it's rare that, you know, Time Magazine or something pulls you out after 15 years and says, you know what the best podcast of the year is? 900% of the world's power broker. Like they don't- This one we've gotten used to, yeah.
是的，完全正确。他们从不那样做。但我认为整个想法、执行方式以及它是如何制作的，然后每个人的反应，知道这是一本值得这样去读的书。我只是，它真的吸引了人们。
Yeah, exactly. They never do that. But because I think the whole idea, the execution and how it was produced and then everyone's reaction to it, knowing that this is a book that makes sense to go through like this. I just, it just really captured people.
就像它，它，它作为一个想法吸引了我。就像我们团队的克里斯·贝鲁比是第一个提出这个想法的人。我当时想，立刻，我就想，是的，我们必须这样做，你知道？然后从那里开始，它只是，我对此非常非常满意。结果非常好。我们得休息一下。当我们回来时，我们会回答一些听众的问题。好吧，所以我们在 Discord 上问了人们一些问题，所以我们将在节目的剩余部分尽可能多地回答这些问题。
Like it, it, it captured me as an idea. Like Chris Berube on our team was the first, the person who pitched it. And I was like, immediate, I was like, yep, we got to do that, you know? And then from there, it just like, I'm just so, so pleased with it. It turned out so well. We've got to take a break. When we we come back we get to some listener questions. Okay, so we have asked people on the discord some questions and so we're gonna get through some of those as many as we can, in the remaining bit of the show.
第一个问题来自吉米·曼戈，可能不是他的真名，但——它是。康涅狄格州的曼戈一家，是的。那是个好名字。问题是，你提出了一个问题，是否有罗伯特·摩西在等待关于他们的传记被写出来，而卡罗认为可能有，是否有罗伯特·摩西在等待关于他们的传记被写出来，
This first question is from Jimmy Mango, probably not his real name, but- It is. The Connecticut Mangos, yeah. That's a great name. The question is, you've posed the question whether there are Robert Moesai waiting for biographies to be written about them, and Carol argues that there might be whether there are Robert Mo's eyes waiting for biographies to be written
而卡罗认为可能有，或者有，但没有同样广泛的长期影响。你调查过那个吗，并发现了其他类似摩西的人物？我想我可以回答这个问题。好吧，所以有趣的是，在常规节目中，我们收到很多记者的投稿，最近有一种趋势，就是，“我想告诉你故事，我想报道多伦多的罗伯特·摩西，或者底特律的罗伯特·摩西，或者洛杉矶的罗伯特·摩西的故事。”他们都是很好的投稿，
about them, and Carrow argues that there might be, or there are, but without the same wide-ranging long-term impact. Have you looked into that at all and found other Moses-like figures? I guess I can answer this. Well, so the funny thing is, is like on the regular show, we get pitches from a lot of reporters, and there's been a flavor of them recently, which is, I want to tell you the story, I want to report the story of the Robert Moses of Toronto, or the Robert Moses of Detroit, or the Robert Moses of LA. And they're all good pitches,
我一点也不贬低他们，但我认为如果你了解那个地方的历史，你会在那个地方找到某种城市建筑恶棍，你可以挂上。有人可以为此负责。那是对的。所以我们有太多这样的了。
I'm not disparaging them at all, but there's a, I think if you know the history of the place, you will find in that place some kind of urban architecture villain that you can hang. Somebody can blame for that. That's right. So we had so many of them.
我想他们中的一些人会自己开绿灯，但我们实际上一直在讨论，我们是否想为人们做一个城市恶棍“疯狂三月”式的括号，来喂养？是的，当然。所以，我们正在考虑如何执行这一点，也许讲述关于许多不同男人的小故事，他们毁了城市，表现得不民主，以及各种其他事情。你知道，我不知道是否有人完全像摩西，
I think some of them will green light on their own, but we've actually been talking about like, do we wanna do like an urban villain march madness style bracket for people, like, to feed into? Yeah, of course. And so, we're thinking about how to execute that and maybe tell littler stories about lots of different men who ruined cities and acted undemocratically and all sorts of other things. You know, I don't know if anyone's quite like Moses
我认为他是，罗伯特·卡罗是对的。但有很多人在我们的城市里做了很多恶作剧，肯定会很有趣去看看他们中的更多人，所以我认为你是对的，他们中没有一个人会成为摩西的直接竞争对手。但我认为这部分是运气。当人们谈论亚伯拉罕·林肯时，他们会说，“好吧，当然他是一位伟大的总统。他在内战期间成为总统，好像那是，当有一个大问题时，变得伟大更容易。”但我认为，他有作为
I think that he's Right Robert Caro is right But there are plenty of people who have done plenty of mischief in our cities and it would be it would be fun to To look at more of them for sure so I I think you're right that none of them will will be direct competitor with Moses. But I think that's partly the luck of it. When people talk about Abraham Lincoln and they're like, well, of course he was a great president. He got to president during the Civil War as if that was like, it's easier to be great when there's a big problem. But I think that the fact that he was that he had the lucky break of being a
纽约建筑师、纽约权力掮客的幸运突破的事实。所以比起全国几乎任何其他城市，都有更大的规模可以操作。但你在各地都有你的农场联盟摩西，你知道，在他们的区域权力中心。我对这个很兴奋。所以这让我想到了，我们正在尝试填补这个括号，
New York based builder, a New York based power broker. And so there's just a bigger scale to operate on than almost any other city in the country. But you have your farm league mosaic all over the place, you know, in their regional power centers. I'm excited about this. So this brings me to like, we're trying to fill this bracket
并试图弄清楚这一点，我们如何在节目中导航。所以如果你有任何，你知道，你所在城市的罗伯特·摩西的提名，我们很乐意开始收集它们，并弄清楚我们如何将它们组合成某种东西。我不太确定怎么做，但我们会
and try to figure this out, how we're going to navigate this on the show. So if you have any, you know, nominations of your Robert Moses of Portland or whatever, we would be delighted to start to collect them and figure out how we're going to put this together into something. I'm not quite sure how to do it, but we'll
弄清楚一些事情。波特兰的罗伯特·摩西就像，“我们必须拆除你的房子来铺设这条自行车道。”那是对的。现在我对波特兰很糟糕。任何其他城市都是。我只是忍不住要神秘化他们。那是对的。现在我对波特兰很糟糕。任何其他城市，是的。我只是忍不住要虐待他们。这太糟糕了。
figure out something. The Robert Moses of Portland is like, we have to tear down your house to put this bike lane through. That's right. Now I'm being terrible to Portland. Any other city is. I just can't help but mystery them. It's right. Now I'm being terrible to Portland. Any other city, yes. I just can't help but mistreat them. It's terrible.
这是真的。所以下一个问题来自特定的安德鲁。不住在纽约，我在读这本书时经常想，那件基础设施这些天怎么样了，特别是每当卡罗对摩西对城市的塑造将是多么永久感到困惑时。
That is true. So next question from specific Andrew. Not living in NYC, I found myself frequently wondering as I read the book, how is that piece of infrastructure doing these days, especially whenever Caro amused about how permanent Moses shaping would be on the city.
你发现哪些摩西项目的更新值得注意，要么是自《权力掮客》写成以来保持相对不变，要么是被拆除，或者可能被改造成更实用的东西？埃利奥特，你比我更有经验。这是一个好问题。我们谈论了一点关于，
What are some of the Moses projects updates that you found notable, either that have stayed relatively unchanged since the power broker was written, or have been demolished, or maybe reworked into something more functional? Elliot, you have more for me, Ernie. It's a good question. We talked a little bit about the,
我希望我有一个更全面的答案。作为我的主要住所，我已经离开纽约好几年了。关于纽约的事情是它总是变化很快。我想我提到了播客。记得科尔森·怀特黑德曾经说过的话吗，他说，你在纽约第一次可以指着同样的东西说，“哦，我知道它以前在这里。”就像它以前是一家鞋店，你知道，我们在播客中提到的某些东西，比如谢伊体育场，它在很大程度上不在那里了。纽约体育馆，不在那里了。
and I wish I had a more comprehensive answer. I've been away from New York for a number of years now as my primary residence. And the thing about New York is it's always changing fast. I think I mentioned the podcast. Remember the thing that I think was Colson Whitehead once said, where he said, you're in New York or the first time you can point to same thing and say, oh, I know it used to be there before this. Like it used to be a shoe store, you know, that there are certain things that we mentioned on the podcast that like Shea Stadium, which is a big part of putting their not there anymore. New York Coliseum, not there anymore.
但这些东西，64 年世博会遗址，无论如何它在某种程度上被建成临时的，但并不是所有在很大程度上不在那里的东西。有人发了一个，是在推特上吗？我不记得了，发给我一张 64 年世博会马赛克的照片，这些马赛克因为多年来人们在上面行走而被毁坏了，这些地面马赛克。还有他建造的其他方面，
But these things that the 64 World's Fair site, which was somewhat built to be temporary anyway, but not all of it that is in large part not there. And someone had sent a was it over Twitter? I can't remember, sent me a picture of these 64 World's Fair mosaics that are just destroyed from years of people walking on them, these ground level mosaics. And there are other aspects that he built,
比如道路总是有点分崩离析。就像任何没有得到适当维护的基础设施的本质一样。但有些部分我认为卡罗是对的，比如他建造的桥梁，它们哪儿也不会去。你知道，它们必须得到维护，但没有人用其他桥梁取代它们。当然，他从填补岛屿之间的空间等方面字面上重塑了城市的地理形状的方式，那在几千年内可能哪儿也不会去。所以有，有些基础设施部分，
like the roads are always falling apart a little bit. Like it's the nature of any infrastructure that's not maintained too properly. But there are certain parts of it where I think Caro's right, like the bridges he built, they're not going anywhere. You know, they'll have to be maintained, but no one is replacing those with other bridges. And certainly the way that he literally reshaped the geographic shape of the city in terms of filling in space between islands and things like that, That's not going anywhere for thousands of years probably. And so there's, there are parts of infrastructure that,
它们是那种，仍然在那里。即使它们在退化，它们对城市的基础设施也非常重要，以至于它们会被维护。但那是，但我认为这就是建造东西的本质，就像，当你建造像摩西那么多东西时，并不是所有东西都会持续下去。并不是他建造的一切都会永远留下来，因为纽约是一个不断变化的城市。它向你展示了他必须在多大的规模上建造，才能制造出不太可能消失的东西，因为纽约建造了这么多建筑，投入了全部心血的人
that are sort of that, that are still there. And even when they're degrading, they're so important to the infrastructure of the city that they will be maintained. But that's, but I think that's the nature of building stuff is that like, when you build as much as Moses did, not all of it's going to last. Not everything he built is going to, is going to stay forever because New York is this constantly changing city. And it shows you what a massive scale he had to build on in order to make things that are not likely to go away because there's so many buildings that were built in New York where the person who put their all into it
说，“这是我的纪念碑。”然后最终它消失了，它不见了。这是一个，这是一个不断变化的城市。关于市政厅有一个古老的传说，它在市中心，他们只在市中心一侧安装了大理石饰面，因为他们想，“没有人会去比市政厅更远的上城。”现在那个东西在市中心太远了，以至于它很荒谬，你知道，就像字面上没有人会看到建筑另一侧的这个。所以，呃，总会有他的东西在退化，但再次强调，它是如此必要，
said, this is my monument. And then eventually it disappeared and it went away. It's such a, it's a constantly changing city. There's the old legend about city hall, which is way downtown that they like only put the marble facing on the downtown side because they're like, nobody's going uptown farther than city hall. And now that thing is so far downtown that like it's ridiculous, you know, like literally no one's going to see this on the other side of the building. And so, uh, there's always going to be stuff of his that is degrading, but again, is so necessary
以至于它会被维护，但随后会有一些东西消失，我希望我有一个更，对于我谈话的时间量，我希望我有一个比这更实质性的答案。我的意思是，我主要是在他没有做的事情，或者他做了的事情，或者他忽视的事情中感觉到它，就像，你知道，地铁的遗产，它在运送人们方面做得非常出色，
that it'll be maintained, but then a few things that'll disappear and I wish I had a more, for the amount of time I talked, I wish I had a more substantive answer than that. I mean, I mainly feel it in the things that he didn't do or he did or he neglected, which is like, you know, the legacy of the subway, which does a remarkable job of moving people around
如果在那 45 年里有同样类型的冠军在任，那可能会更好。那是某种我感觉到的他的遗产，另一部分是，我的意思是他的基础设施，这些天怎么样了？我的意思是，他影响的总体性，你知道，甚至从这个拥堵定价的事情来看，这十年来断断续续的计划，你知道，所有这些事情，基本上是摩西的错。好观点，那些事情，
That probably could have been better had it had the same kind of Champion in office for those, you know 45 years That's something I sort of feel as a legacy of his the other part is like I mean his infrastructure How is it doing these days? I mean, and the totality of of his impact, you know, even from this congestion pricing thing, which the stop and start plan for a decade, you know, all that sort of stuff is is really something that's it's really he built that to like the opposition that is built into that is, is Moses' fault, basically. Good point that the things,
就像不仅仅是他建造的东西，还有他在政治上留下的环境。而且你知道，在情感上，人们成长的世界，现在在纽约，那是他们假设的世界，他们对变化感到愤怒，这是一种多方面的影响。你可以指出这样一个事实，即，
it's like not just the things he built, but the environment that he left behind politically as well. And you know, emotionally, the world that people grew up in and now that's in New York, and that's the world that they assume, and they get mad at changes, and it's a multifaceted impact. And you could point to the fact that like,
从皇后区到城市东侧，然后再到西侧需要很长时间，就像那是从皇后区到城市东侧，然后再到西侧。就像那是地铁。就像那仍然是一个遗产，地铁系统没有按照它可能应该的方式建造，或者按照它应该的方式维护。这是选择的遗产。但随后有讽刺意味的是，讽刺的是，我正在思考他如此
it takes forever to get from Queens over to the east side of the city, and then over to the west side, like that's on to get from Queens over to the east side of the city and then over the west side. Like that's on the subway. Like that's still a legacy that the subway system didn't get built out the way that it probably should have or maintained the way. And it's a legacy of choices. But then there's the ironic, ironically, I was thinking the piece of it that he was so
兴奋去做的那部分，我认为那实际上会是第一件被取代的东西，就是那个穿过建筑的中城高速公路。因为他太迷恋这个想法了。我不得不想象，如果他死的那一刻，他们会说，“拆掉它，不能有它，不，谢谢，这行不通。”每隔一段时间，一辆车就会意外地从这条高速公路飞进中城，
excited to do, which I think would actually would have been the first thing that would have been replaced is that Midtown expressway that would go through buildings. Because he was so enamored of this idea. And I have to imagine that if the moment he died, they would have been like, tear that down, can't have it, no thank you, this is not working. Every now and then a car just accidentally flies off of this expressway into midtown,
就像我们不能再这样了。那是对的。我的意思是，有人在聊天中提到他可能会嫉妒收取所有这些拥堵定价的通行费。如果他能收取，无论多少美元，很多很多美元。九美元。我不知道他是否会进行这种真正的意志之战，
like we can't have this anymore. That's right. I mean, someone has mentioned in the chat that he might be jealous of collecting the tolls on all that congestion pricing. If he could have collected, whatever, I don't even know how many dollars it is, many, many dollars. Nine dollars. I wonder if he would have had this real battle of wills
就像，“我想要钱，但我也想让车更容易进来。”啊，嗯。你知道，这些通行费相对便宜，但这会很难。我认为最终，钱会流出去。是的，是的。所以来自特定的安德鲁，他说，当我参观尼亚加拉的发电厂时，
of like, I want the money, but I also want the cars to get in more easily. Ah, hmm. You know, these tolls are relatively inexpensive, but it would have been hard. I think in the end, the money would have went out though. Yeah, yeah. So from specific Andrew, he says, when I visited the power plant in Niagara,
这是他建造的仍然存在的东西之一，我对我的伴侣说，“我很确定那个东西是以罗伯特·摩西命名的，但书还没有写到它。”但书从来没有写到它，这是我们谈到这本书时不断开的一个持续的笑话。他实际上做了这么多事情真是太有趣了，这很搞笑。有一整章关于公园里的莎士比亚和关于它的争论，以及这个巨大的动力大坝，我不得不想象环境影响是
this is one of the things he built that remains, I said to my partner, I'm pretty sure that thing is named after Robert Moses, but the book hasn't gotten to it yet. But the book never did, which is an ongoing joke that we keep on making when it comes to this book. It's so funny how much more he actually did, which is hilarious. That there is a whole chapter about Shakespeare in the park and the argument over that, and this enormous power dam that I have to imagine the environmental impact is
可能很大。我不得不想象在为人们带来电力方面对人们生活的影响可能很大，而卡罗说，“是纽约市吗？不，谢谢，不感兴趣，别担心。”是长岛地区吗？不，好吧，没关系，忘了它。这是一个，有几次，我非常喜欢这本书，它充满了东西，它是如此宝贝，有几次，我非常喜欢这本书，它充满了东西，它是如此宝贝，你不想在里面塞更多东西，但有几次它就像《纽约客》封面的那一代历史文学版本，
probably huge. I have to imagine the impact on people's lives in terms of bringing electricity to people was probably huge and Carol's like, was it New York City? No thanks, not interested, don't worry about it. Was it at least in the Long Island area? No, okay, never mind, forget it. It's such a, there are times, I love this book so much and it's so full of things and it's so baby, there are times, I love this book so much, and it's so full of things, and it's so baby, you don't want more stuff stuffed into it, but there are times when it is like the once in a generation historical literature version of the New Yorker cover,
在那里，它是《纽约客》对世界的看法，你住的街道很大，一个街区外稍微小一点，然后在远处的某个地方是全国的其他地方，然后在那之外是写着“亚洲”的点，你知道？那就是，有几次书有点像那样。
where it's in New Yorker's view of the world, and the street you live on is huge, and a block away is a little bit smaller, and then somewhere in the distance is like the rest of the country, and then beyond that is the dot that says Asia, you know? And that's like, there's times when the book is a little bit like that.
是的，是的，是的。在那里，你知道，布朗克斯以北的一切就像纽约上州，你知道？这真的会困扰人们。我会说，“哦，那个人现在住在上州。”他们说，“不，他们住在威彻斯特。”那不是那么远的上州。不，是的，它在城市以北，所以。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Where everything, you know, like north of the Bronx is like upstate New York, you know? It really, it would bother people. I'd be like, oh, that person lives upstate now. They're like, no, they live like in Westchester. That's not that far upstate. No, yeah, it's north of the city, so.
这个问题来自 Kiss GZ。我对摩西带来的变化与 70 年代中期城市财政危机的关系很感兴趣。在《恐惧之城》一书中，这没有直接解释，但我怀疑这两个故事有很大联系。福特总统和他的圈子确信，这座城市通过鲁莽、挥霍的支出给自己带来了问题。我推测
This question is from Kiss GZ. I'm interested in how the changes Moses has brought about relate to the city's fiscal crisis in the mid-70s. In the book Fear City, this is not directly explained, but I suspect that the two stories are very much connected. President Ford and his circle was convinced that the city had brought its problems on itself through heedless, profligate spending. And I presume
这个问题来自Kiss GZ。我对摩西带来的变革与70年代中期城市财政危机之间的联系很感兴趣。在《恐惧之城》一书中，这一点并没有直接解释，但我怀疑这两个故事有着密切的联系。福特总统及其圈子确信，这座城市是因为肆无忌惮、挥霍无度的开支才导致了自身的问题。我推测
that spending was mostly Moses. Yet interestingly, he is only mentioned twice in that book, once as the legendary planner, as if he had nothing to do with what happened in 1975. Do you have any thoughts on this, Elliot? I do indeed have thoughts on this, Roman. I mean, the main thing is that I think it's it's not quite fair, I think to say New York is out of money because Robert Moses spent all the money because So much of the money he was playing with didn't come straight from the city's coffers You know a lot of federal money lost his tribal money But I think that he is related to it in that
那笔开支主要归功于摩西。但有趣的是，他在那本书中只被提到了两次，其中一次还是作为传奇规划师，仿佛 1975 年发生的事情与他毫无关系。艾略特，你对此有什么看法？我确实有想法，罗曼。我的意思是，最主要的一点是，我认为说“纽约没钱了是因为罗伯特·摩西花光了所有钱”并不完全公平，因为他所支配的很多资金并非直接来自市财政。你知道，很多是联邦资金，还有他自己的权力资金。但我认为他与此有关，因为
The real issue with the city in the 70s, much of it, was not just that it was out of money, but also but that it did not have the infrastructure to care for the people who lived there and to provide the services they needed. And that is very much a Robert Moses legacy. That that transit around the city was difficult, that public recreation for the lesser served portions of the city continued to be lesser served. That really poured into the social and cultural issues the city was dealing with, which are the things that led to so much of the like, the middle class leaving the city and things like that. And brought us to the period in New York history, which I was born just too late to be a part
70 年代纽约市真正的问题，很大程度上不仅是没钱了，而且是它没有基础设施来照顾居住在那里的人民，并提供他们所需的服务。这在很大程度上是罗伯特·摩西留下的遗产。城市交通困难，为城市中服务较差地区提供的公共娱乐设施依然得不到改善。这确实加剧了城市正在处理的社会和文化问题，而这些问题导致了中产阶级大量离开城市等等。这把我们带到了纽约历史上的那个时期，我出生得太晚，没能亲身经历，
of, but which I grew up hearing stories about so much, the kind of like 70s into the very early 80s New York, where it seems like you were either going to see the first show of the greatest bands that ever played, or you were getting mugged at knife point. And there was no, that was your day. There was the two things that you were doing and nothing else. You know, you spent your, your morning at the forefront of an artistic revolution. And then at night someone hit you in the back of the head and stole your rent money. Like that was it. Like that was New York. It's like the New York my parents would tell me about
但我从小就听过很多关于那个时期的故事，那种从 70 年代到 80 年代初的纽约，似乎你要么会去看有史以来最伟大乐队的首场演出，要么就会在刀尖下被抢劫。没有别的，这就是你的一天。你只有这两件事可做，别无其他。你知道，你把早晨花在了一场艺术革命的最前沿。然后到了晚上，有人从背后袭击你，偷走了你的房租钱。就是这样。这就是纽约。就像我父母告诉我的那个纽约，
where they'd be like, oh yeah, yeah, well, we couldn't walk by Port Authority because there was a guy who's still in the street corner and would just punch people in the stomach. And it's like, oh, this was like a local fixture. This was not something that happened one day. So the city that he left behind is part of it, but I don't know if it's necessarily money specific.
他们会说，哦，是的，我们没法走过港务局，因为那里有个家伙一直站在街角，专门打人的肚子。这就像是当地的一个固定景观。这不是某一天偶然发生的事情。所以他留下的城市是其中的一部分，但我不知道这是否一定与金钱有关。
You had a point that you made throughout the podcast, Roman, that I think bears on here about New York's relationship with money. Well, the common theme every chapter is New York was broke, like constantly. So I have a hard time believing that, I mean, he maybe made it more broke, but it was constantly broke, which is part of his power, was like he was able to secure this money from, you know, a lot of it federal and outside sources and from, you know, from tolls and stuff like that, and bonds and, you know, these perpetual, like forever existing public authorities. And so that can't be new.
罗曼，你在播客中一直提到的一个观点，我认为与纽约和金钱的关系有关。嗯，每一章的共同主题都是纽约没钱了，就像一直如此。所以我很难相信，我的意思是，他可能让它变得更穷了，但它一直都很穷，这也是他权力的一部分，他能够从联邦和外部来源，以及从通行费之类的东西，还有债券，以及那些永久存在的公共机构中获得资金。所以这不可能是新鲜事。
He just was, you know, it was a certain type of extractor of resources. And that's fine when you're in the good extracting stage where there's plenty, but then you hit a wall and all of a sudden that extraction has its most, you know, like painful cost. And I think he was running out his string in the 70s even if he was an immortal who could Live forever and keep going he he just couldn't extract anymore He had kids squeeze the juice out of the city and was like, uh, but I still I mean the fact that his It feels like his dreams went from the visionary dreams of a young man Who's seeing things on a scale no one else can see to the visionary dreams of a kind of a tyrant,
他只是，你知道，他是一种特定类型的资源提取者。当你处于资源充足的良好提取阶段时，这没问题，但当你撞上南墙，突然之间，这种提取就产生了最痛苦的代价。我认为他在 70 年代已经强弩之末了，即使他是一个能长生不老并继续前进的不朽之人，他也无法再提取了。他已经榨干了这座城市的汁液，但我仍然认为，他的梦想似乎从一个年轻人看到别人看不到的规模的远见卓识，变成了某种暴君的远见卓识，
who is, he realizes he has the power to do things that he can't see, to the dreams of a madman who is like, ah, why does the city need people when it could have roads? And like, he had one solution for everything, and it was roads, and he eventually went, it seems to have gone mad with it.
他意识到自己有能力做一些他看不见的事情，变成了疯子的梦想，就像是，啊，为什么城市需要人，当它能拥有道路时？他为一切问题提供了一个解决方案，那就是道路，他最终似乎为此而疯狂了。
And so, yeah, I think you're right, by the 70s, he was less of a, he was still an entity to be feared, but not as much of the creator that he once was. But you can definitely feel the city of the 70s, that the book Fear City and the question is evoking, in the title which is The Fall of New York, which you wouldn't write that as a subtitle today.
所以，是的，我认为你是对的，到了 70 年代，他不再是一个，他仍然是一个令人恐惧的存在，但不再是他曾经那样的创造者了。但你绝对能感受到 70 年代的城市，那本《恐惧之城》和书名中唤起的那个问题，即《纽约的陷落》，你今天不会把它写成副标题。
And there's a certain, you can tell the moment it was written in because there's a lot of Robert Carragall and you know, like the way things are bad now, which really changed in these 50 years in interesting ways. It didn't get all better, but it definitely changed. And so it's interesting. Yeah, that the book is, I think that while he's writing it, he's very much thinking of it as a work of reporting
而且你可以看出它写作的时刻，因为里面有很多罗伯特·卡罗的影子，你知道，比如现在的情况有多糟糕，这 50 年来确实发生了有趣的变化。情况并没有完全好转，但确实改变了。所以这很有趣。是的，我认为他在写这本书时，非常把它当作一篇关于当下以及导致当下的事物的报道。
of the now and the things that led to the now. There's a criticism of the book that's come up on the 50th anniversary, which is like, it's not as accurate about New York state as it once was. It's like, well, yeah, I hope not. It's 50 years like the city can't rebound in a half a century, then nobody should live there. But he's very much writing it from the point of view of this is the world that Moses made and we're living in it.
在 50 周年纪念时，对这本书出现了一种批评，即它对纽约州的描述不再像过去那样准确了。就像是，好吧，是的，我希望如此。已经 50 年了，如果这座城市在半个世纪里都无法反弹，那么就不应该有人住在那里。但他非常从“这就是摩西创造的世界，我们生活在其中”的角度来写。
And it stinks as opposed to now when it's so much more of that is in the in the rearview mirror, because we're all driving on expressways because the subway's not working right now. Right. This question is from Captain Ben. As someone who grew up in Cincinnati, every time I think of a massive highway that cuts through the center of downtown,
而且它很糟糕，与现在相比，因为现在更多的是在后视镜里，因为我们都在高速公路上开车，因为地铁现在运行不正常。好的，这个问题来自本队长。作为一个在辛辛那提长大的人，每当我想到穿过市中心中心的一条巨大高速公路时，
I now think of Moses and his acolytes as they spread his gospel over the country. Has anyone found evidence or history on the direct impact Moses' infrastructure philosophy had on other US cities during the mid century? Yeah, that's something we talked about with Robert Caro and it's something that comes up a lot of like how important is this Robert Moses really because this was happening in a lot of places and Robert Caro's response was that
我现在就会想到摩西和他的追随者，因为他们把他的福音传遍了全国。有没有人发现摩西的基础设施哲学在世纪中叶对其他美国城市产生直接影响的证据或历史？是的，这是我们和罗伯特·卡罗讨论过的事情，也是经常出现的问题，即这个罗伯特·摩西到底有多重要，因为这种情况在很多地方都在发生，而罗伯特·卡罗的回应是，
Moses taught people that you could destroy neighborhoods with little or no repercussions in a modern democracy. You could do that as an imperial power. Yeah, totally. Yes. There's a real question, I think, this is something that comes up a lot.
摩西教导人们，在现代民主国家，你可以摧毁社区而几乎不需要承担后果。你可以像帝国强权一样行事。是的，完全正确。是的，我认为这是一个真正的问题，这经常被提及。
I was bringing up Abraham Lincoln. Something people talk about Abraham Lincoln is like, how much was he guiding events? How much was he guided by events? And Moses is kind of similar that he is someone who was very much at the forefront of this switch to a road based lifestyle, especially in cities. And he was someone who was working on again, and the biggest showpiece in America, New York City.
我提到了亚伯拉罕·林肯。人们谈论亚伯拉罕·林肯时会说，他在多大程度上引导了事件？他在多大程度上被事件所引导？摩西也有点类似，他是一个非常处于这种向基于道路的生活方式转变的前沿的人，特别是在城市中。而且他再次工作，在美国最大的展示窗口，纽约市。
But at the same time, he was like, in the mainstream, he was not pushing against the currents of the culture. This was something that everybody was interested in. I mean, this is he's working before that the federal interstate highway system, but that feeling is in the air and at the like, the 39 World's Fair, there's the Futurama exhibit, which is kind of an exhibit of what life will be like in the future. And driving commuting between work and home over highways with cars is a big part of that.
但与此同时，他在主流中并没有逆文化潮流而行。这是每个人都感兴趣的事情。我的意思是，他在联邦州际公路系统之前就在工作，但那种感觉弥漫在空气中，在 39 年世博会上，有 Futurama 展览，这是一种关于未来生活会是什么样子的展览。在高速公路上开车往返于工作和家庭之间是其中的重要组成部分。
I mean, it's a general motorist thing, which is why it was a big part of it. But the idea of living a highway driving based lifestyle and being able to get in and out of cities easily is already in the zeitgeist, but he manages to like capture that zeitgeist and work with it at a level that nobody else is. And, uh, and, uh, comparison that, uh, that came up when we were kind of discussing this, uh, earlier today, which I think is still relevant is, uh, that there's a lot of musicians who are kind of doing the same kind of thing as Taylor Swift, but they're not doing it in the way that connects to people the same
我的意思是，这是一种普遍的驾车者心态，这就是为什么它是其中的重要部分。但过一种基于高速公路驾驶的生活方式，并能轻松进出城市的想法已经存在于时代精神中，但他设法捕捉到了这种时代精神，并以一种无人能及的水平与之合作。而且，今天早些时候我们在讨论这个时，出现了一个比较，我认为仍然相关，那就是，有很多音乐家在做和泰勒·斯威夫特一样的事情，但他们并没有以同样的方式与人们建立联系。
way. Nobody would say Taylor Swift is like a, like a revolutionary artist who is changing the rules of the game, but she does what she's doing at this level that resonates and impacts clearly at a higher level for people, and so in many ways, I think Robin Rose is similar. He's the Taylor Swift of mid-century highway building. He's doing what everybody else is doing,
没有人会说泰勒·斯威夫特是一个改变游戏规则的革命性艺术家，但她以这种水平做她正在做的事情，这在更高层面上引起了人们的共鸣和影响，所以在很多方面，我认为罗伯特·摩西是相似的。他是世纪中叶公路建设界的泰勒·斯威夫特。他在做每个人都在做的事情，
but he's just doing it so much better. He's doing it on a global scale. All I see now in the chat is several people are typing. Yeah, I'm not saying Taylor Swift is bad. This is a, oh, I should never said it, sorry. Oh my goodness, okay. Look, my kids are fans of hers. We hear a lot of it at the house.
但他做得好得多。他在全球范围内做这件事。我现在在聊天中看到的只有几个人在打字。是的，我不是说泰勒·斯威夫特不好。这是一个，哦，我不该说的，抱歉。天哪，好吧。看，我的孩子们是她的粉丝。我们在家里听了很多。
I love Taylor Swift. You're alone on this island. I didn't say she was bad. This is a compliment to Robert Moses. I see. I see. The only thing I've seen like this is when we did a Flophouse show once where we did the movie
我喜欢泰勒·斯威夫特。你在这个岛上是孤独的。我没说她不好。这是对罗伯特·摩西的赞美。我明白了。我明白了。我见过唯一类似的事情是我们有一次做 Flophouse 节目，我们做了电影
Spice World. And one of my co-hosts mentioned that the Spice Girls were kind of an artificially brought together band. And the audience booed him so hard. I heard that episode. That's so good. Yeah. It was so funny. Okay, so from JML 18, how do you think we find the balance between Moses's build first, ask questions later style of infrastructure projects and what many see today as over regulation, which can stymie attempts to undertake majority infrastructure
《辣妹世界》。我的一位联合主持人提到辣妹组合是一个人为拼凑的乐队。观众对他嘘声一片。我听过那一集。太棒了。是的。太搞笑了。好的，来自 JML 18，你认为我们如何在摩西那种“先建设，后问话”的基础设施项目风格，与许多人今天所看到的过度监管之间找到平衡，因为过度监管可能会阻碍在现代城市进行重大基础设施
improvements in modern cities. That's a great question. I feel like I'm not, that's above my pay grade. Roman, you've been a hosting at an urban design and so forth, I guess for a while, I think you could talk more about it. Yeah, I mean, you hear this a lot that there should be a Robert Moses for X or there would be good to have Robert Moses pointed in the direction that you want things to go and I understand that I do think that the nature of
改善的尝试。这是一个很好的问题。我觉得我不是，那超出了我的薪酬等级。罗曼，你主持城市设计之类的节目已经有一段时间了，我想你可以谈谈。是的，我的意思是，你经常听到应该有一个罗伯特·摩西来做 X，或者如果有一个罗伯特·摩西朝着你想要的方向引导事情会很好，我理解这一点。我确实认为
politics is this push and pull of regulation and deregulation. And see, I still kind of have a way of blaming Robert Moses for a lot of this, which is like, he broke systems to make things dependent on him and his choices and roads and stuff. And so we had to fight back by creating things that were more fair and more democratic. And so he's kind of at fault for both aspects, for both building things with sort of undemocratically acquired power, and also he's at fault for democratically acquired power for not being able to do things quickly
政治的本质是监管和去监管的推拉。而且，我仍然有一种把很多责任归咎于罗伯特·摩西的方式，那就是，他破坏了系统，使事物依赖于他、他的选择和道路等等。所以我们不得不通过创造更公平、更民主的事物来进行反击。所以他在这两个方面都有过错，既因为以某种非民主获得的权力建设事物，也因为民主获得的权力无法快速做事，
because we were trying to stop future Robert Moses in a lot of these ways. I get it that maybe it is too far and you just have to go to, or listen in on a Berkeley City Council meeting of NIMBYs and go like, why can they stop things from happening that need to happen? And then you read a similar thing happening
因为我们试图在很多方面阻止未来的罗伯特·摩西。我明白，也许这太过分了，你只需要去听听伯克利市议会关于邻避主义者的会议，然后说，为什么他们能阻止需要发生的事情发生？然后你读到《权力掮客》中发生的类似事情，你希望那些声音在那种情况下有更多的权力。所以困难的部分是，需要做出正确的平衡。如果更多的人关注并投票参加地方选举，并关注这些事情，一切都会运作得更好。如果他们是你同意的人，罗曼，
in the Power Broker and you wish that those voices had more power in that situation. So the hard part is, is like, there is the right balance to be made. It would all work better if more people focused and voted on local elections and paid attention to these things. If they were the people you agreed with, Roman,
砰，抓到你了。不，但我的意思是，我认为两者都是。就像你只是关注它并试图让它做出反应。但你确实需要推拉。就像我认为所有好的设计都来自自上而下的规划，以及自下而上、稍微非正式的公民让他们的社区尽可能好的过程。
boom, gotcha. No, but I mean, I think both. Like you just pay attention to it and try to make it responsive. But you do, you need to push and pull. Like I think all good design comes from top-down planning and also a ground up, a little bit more informal process of the citizens making their neighborhood as good
但我们确实很快且容易失去平衡，这很遗憾。但很多时候我在读这本书时，我有点庆幸罗伯特·摩西没有更邪恶，你知道吗？考虑到所有这些，他本可以做的事情，以及他仍然相当致力于公园之类的事情，这真是令人惊奇。你完全可以想象一个更糟糕的人会采取更多自由，真正彻底摧毁一切，而且在某种程度上自我致富，这绝对令人难以置信。我认为关于它我唯一要说的是，找到这种平衡太难了，因为你无法预知未来。
as they can. But we do get out of balance pretty quickly and easily, and that's a shame. But a lot of the time when I'm reading this book, I'm kind of grateful that Robert Moses wasn't more evil, you know? Given all that stuff, what he could have done, and that he was still pretty dedicated to parks and things like that, is kind of amazing. You could totally imagine a worse person taking way more liberties and really truly destroying everything, and also like self-enriching to an extent that was absolutely mind-boggling. I think it's the only thing I have to say about it is that it's so hard to find that balance I think because you can't tell the future.
所以你不知道一件事的后果，直到它真正完成。你可以猜测它们，你可以估计它们。但它太难了，所以我们很容易回顾《权力掮客》，说，这是一件好事，这是一件坏事，我希望他做了这个，我很高兴他做了这个，我希望他没做这个。但当有人给你带来一个新计划时，很难知道这一点。我的意思是，有时很清楚哪些事情不好，有时看起来很
So you don't know the consequences of a thing until it's done, really. You can guess at them, you can estimate them. But it's so hard and so it is easy for us to look back at the power broker and be like, this was a good thing, this was a bad thing, I wish he'd done this, I'm glad he did this, I wish he hadn't done this. But it's harder to know that when someone is bringing a new plan to you. I mean, sometimes it's very clear what things are not good and sometimes it seems really
清楚哪些事情是好的，但这只是很难。你永远无法知道一件事的真正影响会是什么，直到多年后，我们还没有时间旅行。但当我们有时间旅行时，我们的决定会容易得多。容易得多。休息后回答更多关于《权力掮客》的问题。但当我们有时间旅行时，我们的决定会容易得多。休息后回答更多关于《权力掮客》的问题。简问，林肯中心的模型是 2021 年版《西区故事》的开场镜头，看着 1961 年的原版电影，我了解到所使用的地点是摩西项目的实际贫民窟
clear what things are good, but it's just hard. You never can know what the real impact of a thing is going to be until, you know, years after the fact and we don't have time travel yet. But when we do, our decisions are going to be a lot easier to make. So much easier. More of your power broker questions answered after the break. But when we do, our decisions are going to be a lot easier to make. More of your power broker questions answered after the break. Jane asks, a mock-up of Lincoln Center is that the opening shot of the 2021 remake of West Side Story looking up the original 1961 film, I learned that the locations used were actual slum
清理现场。自从读了《权力掮客》后，还有什么媒体让你大喊“罗伯特·摩西”，并对着屏幕挥舞拳头吗？这是一个好问题。我觉得我现在看《制片人》中的那个镜头，吉恩·怀尔德和泽罗·莫斯泰尔站在林肯中心的喷泉旁，当他说“我想要我在电影中看到的一切”时，喷泉喷涌而出。就像他们决定要从所有这些老太太那里偷钱来资助这部
clearance sites from Moses projects. Is there any other media that since reading The Power Broker has you shouting, Robert Moses, shaking your fist at the screen? That's a good question. I feel like I now look at the shot in The Producers where Gene Wilder and Zero Mostel are standing at the fountain in Lincoln Center and the fountain goes off when he goes, I want everything I've ever seen in the movies. Like and they decide they are going to steal money from all these old ladies to fund this
糟糕的戏剧。就像现在我更多地把它看作是一个罗伯特·摩西时刻，你知道，但我必须承认，当我观看关于纽约的电影时，我花太多时间试图识别我亲身去过的地方，以至于我并不总是对事物有历史性的看法。相反，我会说，我知道那个街角。多年前有一部非常糟糕的低成本电影叫《机器人与家庭》，几乎完全是在百老汇 14 街和 12 街之间的一段街道上拍摄的，那里只是一堆古董店。
bad play. Like now I think of that more as a Robert Moses moment, you know, but I have to admit when I watch movies at New York, I spend so much time trying to identify places I've been in person that I don't always have the historical view of things. Instead, I'm like, I know that street corner. There's a very bad low budget movie from years ago called Robot and the Family that was shot almost entirely in one stretch of street of Broadway between like 14th Street and 12th Street, where it's just a bunch of antique stores.
当时我就想，我上大学时每天多次走过那条街，看着它。现在我喜欢这部电影，尽管它很糟糕，因为它把我带回了那些日子。你呢，有没有什么，作为一个没住在纽约，所以没有那种个人偏见蒙蔽你的人，自从那以后你看到过什么
And I was like, at the time, and I was like, I used to walk that street multiple times a day when I was a college student and watch it. Now I love this movie, even though it's terrible, because it brings me back to those days. What about you, is there anything, as someone who didn't live in New York, and so don't have that personal bias blinding you, are there things that you've seen since then
让你觉得“那是罗伯特·摩西的东西”？嗯，我最喜欢的电影之一是比尔·默瑞的电影《快变》，他在那里打扮成小丑抢劫银行，并试图离开城市。关于你如何到达 BQE 以及你如何做这个和那个，一切都非常令人困惑。直到这次重读，我才知道那部电影的反派实际上是罗伯特·摩西。这就是他们无法离开城市的原因。这让我更加欣赏那部电影。
where you're like, that's a Robert Moses thing? Well, one of my favorite movies is the Bill Murray movie, Quick Change Change where he robs a bank, dresses a clown, and is trying to get out of the city. And it's all very confusing about how you get to the BQE and how you do this and how you do that. And I never knew until this reread that the villain of that movie is actually Robert Moses. That's the reason why they can't make it out of the city. And it makes me appreciate that movie even more.
但这是我能想到的一个。每当我看到那种，特别是那些 70 年代的电影，我只是觉得那是他创造的城市，这有点，当我观看像《地铁惊魂》之类的电影时，我绝对能感受到它们。哦，多棒的电影，我得找时间看那部《地铁惊魂》。
But that's one I can think of. Anytime I see a kind of, especially those movies from, you know, like I love those movies from the 70s and I just feel like that's the city he created and it's sort of, I definitely feel them when I watch, like taking home 123 and stuff like that. Oh, what a great movie, I'll time to take that one, three.
我本来想开个关于你的刻薄玩笑，我说，嗯，我知道罗曼作为一个不是来自纽约的人，当你观看关于纽约的电影时，你大多会说，加夫，看看那些建筑有多大。没错。看看那些大建筑，是的。等等，聊天中有一点讨论
The, I was gonna make a mean joke about you, I'm like, well, I know Roman as someone who's not from New York, when you're watching movies at New York, you're mostly going, Garf, look at how big those buildings are. That's right. Look at them big buildings, yeah. Wait, there's a little bit of talk in the chat
关于《地铁惊魂》。我会说，对于任何想要体验那种 70 年代纽约的人来说，如果你还没看过原版《地铁惊魂》，它就像是 1974 年身处纽约的一剂浓缩的、直接的肾上腺素。我真的很喜欢它。对我来说，它是了解那个时代的一扇窗户。
about the Taken of Palom 123. I will say, for anyone who wants a taste of that 70s New York, if you haven't seen the original taking of Palom 123, it's such a concentrated, like, straight shot of adrenaline of being in New York in 1974. I really love it so much. It's such a window for me into that time.
总之，所以我推荐它。哦，它太棒了。我们在做这个项目时我又重看了一遍，它完全经得起考验。它也让你意识到地铁实际上发生了多大的变化。你知道，就像涂鸦的数量，发生的事情的数量，
Anyway, so I recommend it. Oh, it's so, so good. I rewatched it again while we were doing this project and it just totally stands up. It also makes you realize how much the subway has actually changed. You know, just like the amount of graffiti, the amount of like stuff that was happening,
就像地铁，你知道，肯定有，你知道，可怕的袭击仍然发生，不是为了淡化它们，但它们，它不仅仅是停滞不前，变得越来越糟，它们实际上已经相当大地改善了地铁及其功能。我记得我小时候，我们经常看《来到美国》，有一个场景是他们上了地铁车厢，外面
just like the subways, you know, definitely have, you know, horrible attacks happen still, not to minimize them, but they've, it's not just in stasis and just gotten worse and worse and worse, they've actually improved the subways and their function quite a bit. I remember when I was a kid, we used to watch Coming to America a lot, and there's a scene where they get on a subway car, and outside of it
覆盖着涂鸦，我记得非常清楚我看到那部电影的那一刻，我看过很多次，我去过纽约很多次，看到它并说，哦，好吧，它们不再那么脏了。我记得当它们像我看到很多次时，我去过纽约很多次，看到它并说，哦，好吧，它们不再那么脏了。就像我记得当它们是那样时，但突然间就像，哦，是的，我上次坐地铁时，它干净多了。
it's covered in graffiti, and I remember so well the moment that I saw that movie, I'd seen it many times, I'd been to New York many times, and seeing it and being like, oh, well they're not dirty like that anymore. I remember when they like I'd seen it many times, I've been to New York many times, and seeing it and being like, oh, well they're not dirty like that anymore. Like I remember when they were, but suddenly it was like, oh yeah, the last time I was on the subway, it was much cleaner.
这部电影不再是最新的了，《来到美国》不再是最新的，不再是头条新闻了。你知道，城市总是在变化。正如我们所说，它不再是 50 年前的那个城市了，这大多是件好事，在某些方面不是件好事，但一切总是在变化。
This movie is not up to date, Coming to America is not up to date, ripped from the headlines anymore. You know, the city is always changing. As we've said, it's not the same city that it was 50 years ago, and that's mostly a good thing, and in some ways not a good thing, but everything's always changing.
关于电影，肯·斯蒂格纳在聊天中问，我对爱德华·诺顿的《布鲁克林孤儿》很好奇，罗伯特·摩西在书中被描绘成摩西·伦道夫。你看过《布鲁克林孤儿》吗？是的，我看过。它对我来说是一部非常好奇的电影，因为我是原作者乔纳森·勒瑟姆的超级粉丝，
Related to movies, Ken Stigner on the chat is asking, I'm curious about your thoughts on Ed Norton's Motherless Brooklyn, which R.M. has depicted as Moses Randolph in the book. Did you see Motherless Brooklyn? Yes, I did. I was so, it's such a curious movie to me because I'm a huge fan of the original author of the author of
那本书根本不是关于罗伯特·摩西的，也不是一个时代故事。它设定在它写作的 1990 年代，而《布鲁克林孤儿》经历了一个漫长的开发过程才成为电影，而且感觉非常清楚，在某个时刻，爱德华·诺顿读了《权力掮客》，觉得那正是电影需要讲述的内容，所以他尽了最大努力。我认为这不是一部完全成功的电影，但我认为它是一部非常好的电影。他正在尽最大努力为纽约，
Jonathan Lethal and That book is very much not about Robert Moses and is also not a period story It's set in the 1990s when it was written and mother's work and went through a long development process to become a movie and it feels Very clear that at some point Ed Norton read the power broken was like that's what the movie needs to be about and so He's trying his best. And I think it's a not entirely successful movie, but I think it is a very good movie. He's trying his best to make for New York,
就像《唐人街》对洛杉矶那样。这种关于城市为什么是现在这个样子，以及它是如何建立在邪恶力量的工作之上的秘密历史，这是一部制作精良的电影。它并没有完全做到它需要做的一切，但我很好奇你怎么看，因为我确实认为它是一部制作精良的电影。它并没有完全做到它需要做的一切，但我很好奇你怎么看，因为我确实认为它是一部好电影。
what Chinatown is to Los Angeles. This kind of like secret history of why the city is the way it is and how it's built on the work of a sinister force, and it's a really well-made movie. It doesn't quite do everything it needs to do, but I'm curious what you think about it, because I do think it's a really well-made movie. It doesn't quite do everything it needs to do, but I'm curious what you think about it, because I do think it is a good movie.
嗯，我只记得去看它，我读了乔纳森·勒瑟姆的书，真的很喜欢它，然后你去看了《布鲁克林孤儿》，第一个场景就是《权力掮客》的第一个场景，你会想，发生了什么？就像，它几乎完全一样。你走到剧院大厅，你会想，有人把电影的标题换了。
Well, I just remember showing up to it, and I read Jonathan Lethal's book and really loved it, and then you go to see Motherless Brooklyn, and the first scene is the first scene from The Power Broker, and you're like, what is going on? Like, it's like almost exactly the same. You wind up to the theater lobby, and you're like, someone switched the titles on the movies.
这不是我以为我会看到的。所以我根本没想到。这对我来说非常奇怪。我不知道版权方面，我想这是历史上发生的事情，但它太，它只是很奇怪。它就像是《权力掮客》中一个场景的改编。所以我也只是，在屏幕上看到它是一种乐趣，特别是一个惊喜。
This is not the one I thought I would see. And so I did not expect it at all. It was very strange to me. I didn't know like copyright wise, I guess it's a thing that happened in history, but it was like so, it was just weird. It was like an adaptation of a scene from The Power Broker. And so I also just, it was kind of a delight to see it on screen, especially as a surprise.
我们曾和爱德华·诺顿的人谈过让他上节目，因为我知道他真的非常关心这些东西。显然，他不知何故把它塞进了这部电影里，没有任何明显的理由。并不是说你读了那本书，然后你会说，你知道吗，这里有一个机会来制作一部关于罗伯特·摩西的时代剧。
We had talked to Ed Norton's people about getting him on the show because I know he really, really cares about this stuff. And obviously like he kind of wedged it into this other movie for no like apparent reason. It's not like you read that book and you're like, you know what, there's an opportunity here to do a period piece about Robert Moses.
它真的感觉像是他把一本书走私进了另一本书。他字面上拿走了《布鲁克林孤儿》的防尘套，把它套在《权力掮客》的封面上，然后把它带进了课堂。但我觉得这很有趣。而且我认为爱德华·诺顿真的很棒。我的意思是，我不知道，我最近看了鲍勃·迪伦的电影，
Like it really does feel like he smuggled one book into another. He literally took Muzzles Brooklyn's dust jacket and put it over the Power Brokers cover and then brought that into class. But like, but I thought it was fun. And I think Ed Norton is really great. I mean, I don't know, I saw the Bob Dylan movie recently
他在里面演皮特·西格演得太好了。这真的很特别，他通常那么紧张，他有那么多的能量和某种凶猛。但他以一种我从未见过的方式扮演了皮特·西格那种平静，他的整张脸都放松了，他的声音也放松了，等等。而且就像，我非常钦佩他。所以我很乐意和他谈谈。
and he's so good as Pete Seeger. Like it's really something like he's usually so nervy and he has so much energy and sort of ferocity in him. And he plays this like, like this, the peaceful calm of Pete Seeger in this way I've never seen his like, his whole face is relaxed and his voice is relaxed and stuff. And it's like, I just, I admire him greatly. So I would have loved to talk to him about it.
我只记得当时被它惊呆了。就像，我心想，哇，这太奇怪了。但是的，我只是被它逗乐了，我认为它是了解它的一扇很好的小窗户。如果它把你带到了《权力掮客》，那太好了，你知道。我的意思是，如果它把你带到了《权力掮客》，那太棒了。
I just remember being just kind of gobsmacked by it. It's just like, I'm like, whoa, this is weird. But yeah, I was just kind of delighted by it and I think it's a good little window into it. And if it brings you to the power broker, then that's great, you know. I mean, if it brings you to the power broker, that's wonderful.
如果它把你带到了乔纳森·勒瑟姆的作品，你知道。是的，完全正确。如果你从那读到《孤独堡垒》，你知道，那太棒了。这也是一本非常棒的书，这让我想到了人们问我们的最后一个问题，来自本·G。我非常感谢这个项目
If it brings you to Jonathan Lethal works, you know. Yeah, totally. If you go from that to reading Forge of Solitude, you know, then that's fantastic. Also a really fantastic book, which brings me to kind of the final question that people have been asking us is from Ben G. I feel immensely grateful for this project
把《权力掮客》带进了我的生活，但现在怎么办？你们最喜欢的一些书是什么？我有很多。所以。也许，给我们一些。所以我猜我最喜欢的，我很难选择。它们确实取决于我的心情，
to bring the Power Broker into my life, but what now? What are some of your favorite books? I have lots of them. So. Maybe, give us some So I guess my favorite, I'm trying to have a hard time. They really are dependent on my mood,
但我最喜欢的另一本值得读很多遍的大长书可能是《孤鸽镇》。我认为读起来很有趣。我认为它真的非常令人愉快。林登·约翰逊的书非常精彩。就像，你知道，我强烈建议直接读完它们。而且我真心认为，我知道这在最后一集里可能是亵渎，但我认为林登·约翰逊的书总的来说——别说出来，罗曼，别说出来。不，但我确实说过，罗曼，你向我指出了这一点，我认为这是真的，他因为在《权力掮客》中的练习而对他能力的控制更加自如。但那些都是好书。
but my favorite other big long book that I think is worth reading probably multiple times is Lonesome Dove. I think it's just fun to read. I think it's really, really enjoyable. The LBJ books are rip roaring good. Like, you know, I highly recommend just like going straight through and read them. And I honestly think, I know it's like,
这非常令人生畏，因为它们太大了，但它们非常易读。那些林登·约翰逊的书。它们超级易读。我认为我们讨论过的一些时间线跳跃的混乱，是为了让《权力掮客》发挥作用，他只是
I don't know if it's sacrilege on this final episode, but I think the LBJ books are collectively- Don't say it, Roman, don't say it. No, but I did say, you've made the point to me, Roman, which I think is true that he is even more in control of his abilities because of the practice he had with the power broker. But those are great books.
似乎在林登·约翰逊的书中有时稍微不那么突兀地平滑了这一点，在那里你总是知道你在哪里。他有更多进入林登·约翰逊思想的窗口，它变得非常情绪化，非常奇怪，就像你在林登·约翰逊的脑子里待了很长时间，这并不完全感觉有趣，因为他太焦虑、太贪婪、太贪婪了，我们从未问过这个，我们从未达到那个点，但我有点想问罗伯特·卡罗在林登·约翰逊的脑子里是什么感觉，因为那看起来不是一个花很多时间的好地方。总之，林登·约翰逊的书很棒。
It's very intimidating because they're huge, but they're so readable. Those Lyndon Johns books. They're super readable. A lot of the stuff that I think, there's some confusion that we talked through of the timeline jumping that happens to make the power broker work, which he just
如果你喜欢其他关于纽约的书，我认为保罗·奥斯特是布鲁克林最伟大的记录者之一。我认为他真的非常棒。其他历史学家，芭芭拉·塔奇曼是我第一个喜欢的历史作家。我认为《骄傲之塔》非常出色。我认为乔·莱波雷的，这几乎是相反的，乔·莱波雷的《这些真理》是对美国历史的真正调查，超级有趣，真的非常有趣。我最喜欢的另一种新闻类书籍是泰德·科诺弗的《新杰克》，他
seems to have smoothed out a way to do that a little less jarring sometimes in the LBJ books, where you always kind of know where you are. He has more of a window into LBJ's thoughts, and it becomes a very emotional, very weird, like you spend a long time inside of LBJ's head which does not feel fun exactly because he's so anxious and needy and greedy and we never asked this, we never got to the point, but I kind of wanted to ask Robert Carroll what it felt like to be inside of LBJ's head, because it doesn't seem like a fun place to spend a lot of time. So anyway, the LBJ books are great.
卧底成为一名惩教官。那本非常出色。你呢？我应该花更多时间思考这个问题，因为这是一个很好的问题。但我认为我可能读过次数最多的非虚构类书籍是《记者与杀手》，我喜欢它。我的意思是，它有帮助，因为它是一本很短的书，
If you like other New York books, I think Paul Oster is one of the great chroniclers of Brooklyn. I think he's really, really fantastic. Other historians, Barbara Tugman was my first sort of love of a history writer. I think The Proud Tower is exceptional. I think Joe Lepore's, it's almost the opposite, Joe Lepore's These Truths is a real like survey of American history and is super fun, really, really fun. My other favorite sort of like journalism book is Ted Conover's New Jack where he goes
但我喜欢那本书。它让我对采访他人的人之间的权力差异有了不同的思考，也让我思考人们如何相互互动，以及本能地开始想要得到他人认可的人的行为，如何改变了他们，你知道，以及它如何改变了他们的行为方式。
undercover as a corrections officer. That one's phenomenal. What about you? I should have put more time into thinking about this because it's a question that is a good question to ask. But the nonfiction book that I think I probably have read the most times is The Journalist and the Murderer, which I love. I mean, it helps that it's journalist and the murderer, which I love. I mean, it helps that it's a very short book,
我非常喜欢那本书。那是一本奇怪的书。那是一本奇怪的书。它的整个故事非常奇怪，是的。但它是一本关于另一本书的书，关于一个真实犯罪案件，而作者成为了这些人动态的一部分，你知道吗？它太奇怪了。
but I love that book. And it made me think so differently about the power difference between people interviewing other people, but also just how people interact with each other and what the actions of someone who instinctively starts to want the approval of another person, how it changes them, you know, and how it changes the way they act.
就像，我最近第一次读它，我心想，这太诡异了。这真的是，它就像新新闻主义在那个时刻的冲击。它感觉就像我是故事中影响故事的人，反馈给故事的顶点。主题正在和我谈论他们的失望，各种各样的事情。它真的很曲折和奇怪。它几乎与《权力掮客》完全相反，罗伯特·卡罗
I love that book so much. That's a weird book. That is weird book. The whole story of it is very strange, yeah. But the fact that it's a book about another book, about a true crime case, and the author becomes part of the dynamic of these people, you know? It is so weird.
就像，作者被告知，哒哒哒，就像他拒绝甚至提到自己。而吉姆就像，当我和这家伙谈话时，但当谈到时，我读了很多小说，而且，我的意思是，我一生中最喜欢的书是，我喜欢 G.K. 切斯特顿的《星期四的人》。我喜欢《爱丽丝梦游仙境》，可能对我来说最重要的书仍然是道格拉斯·亚当斯的《银河系漫游指南》，它是，我只是，
Like, I just read it recently for the first time, and I was just like, this is freaky. This is a real, it's just sort of like new journalism hitting at this moment. It just feels like the apex of I'm the person in the story affecting the story, feeding back to the story. The subject is talking to me about their disappointment and me, all sorts of stuff. It's really twisty and strange. It's almost the exact opposite of the power broker where Robert Carrow
我去年重读了所有书之后，现在正在给我的大儿子大声朗读它们。我去年 42 岁了。所以我心想，为了我的 42 岁，我得再读一遍《银河系漫游指南》。所以这是 42 本书。那是一本我发现的，它是一本短书，我真的会大声
was like, it was said to the author that, da da da, like it refused to even name himself. And Jim was like, when I was talking to this guy, but when it comes to, I read a lot of fiction and, uh, I mean, my, my favorite books of all time are like, uh, I love the man who was Thursday by GK Chesterton. I love Alice in Wonderland and probably the book above all books for me is still maybe The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy by Douglas Adams, which is, I just am,
笑出来，但我从中发现了太多的意义。里面有很多东西，我觉得非常丰富，对我很有意义。它帮助我度过了我需要帮助才能度过的时期。所以这些是浮现在我脑海中的书，但我应该想到更多的非虚构类书籍。我的意思是，除了那个之外，最喜欢的非虚构类书籍，罗伯特·卡罗的《权力掮客》一路领先，就是 PB，权力掮客。我的意思是，它仍然是我最喜欢的。我只是注意到他在读完其他书时发展的技巧，每一本书都相当不同。
I'm now reading those aloud to my older son after rereading them all last year. I turned 42 last year. And so I was like, for my 42nd year, I gotta read The Hitchhiker's Guide again. So it's the 42 books. And that's a book that I find, it's a short book that I genuinely laugh out
第一本书感觉最像《权力掮客》，有很多深入的研究和历史来解释事情。第二本书基本上是一部关于他窃取第一次国会选举并将科克·史蒂文森赶下台的惊悚片。然后《参议院的主人》基本上是一本围绕着 350 页整个参议院机构历史的历史的大书。
loud at, but I find so much meaning in it. There's so much in it that I find very rich and meaningful to me. And that has helped me through times that I need help to get through. And so those are the ones that kind of come to the top of my mind, but I should have thought of more non-fiction books. I mean, favorite non-fiction book other than that, General Slammer's, Power Broker all the way, just PB, Power Broker. I mean, it's still my favorite too. I just noticed his developing craft as he gets through the other books, and each of them is quite a bit different.
这太令人惊奇了。它们真的非常令人惊奇。我认为另一种方式，如果你想，短历史，我认为我喜欢的一位被低估的历史作家是保罗·柯林斯。他写了一本叫《班瓦德的愚行》的书，我一直很喜欢。我只是喜欢他的叙事风格。
The first book kind of feels most like the Power Broker, a lot of deep dive and history to explain things. The second book is like basically a thriller about like him stealing his first congressional election and putting out the pasture of Coke Stevenson. And then the Master of the Senate is basically a large book wrapped around a 350 page history of the entire Senate body history.
有太多好书了。如果你想读一本对城市市政基础设施及其失败有不同看法的书，那么我想我会推荐大友克洋的漫画《阿基拉》的前四卷，它表面上是关于通灵儿童和摩托车帮派的，但它，但在表面之下，还有他的恐怖故事《童梦》，它们都是关于东京普通城市居民的巨大基础设施失败。《童梦》是关于这个巨大的住房综合体，里面再次有一个老头，是一个通灵杀手，而这里再次是关于通灵儿童和摩托车帮派。
And it's just amazing. They're really, really amazing. I think another way, if you wanna, short histories, I think sort of an undersung history author I like is Paul Collins. He wrote a book called Banvard's Folly, which I've always just kind of loved. And I just like his storytelling style.
但其中很多是关于人们反抗或被系统、城市基础设施系统压垮。当这些系统要么运行不正常，要么彻底失败时会发生什么，比如当一个通灵儿童释放出一波 TK 力量，夷平了城市。但如果你从市政基础设施的角度来看待这些，
There's so many good books. If you wanna read a book that is a different take on urban municipal infrastructure and its failings, then I think I would kind of recommend the first four volumes of Katsuhiro Otomo's manga Akira, which is ostensibly about psychic children and biker gangs, but it, but under the surface, and also his horror story, Domo, they are both about massive infrastructure failures for ordinary urban dwellers in Tokyo. Domo is about this huge housing complex that has, again, an old man who's a kind of psychic murderer and here again is about psychic children and bike gangs.
我认为里面有很多东西可以发现。而且它，它只是，它只是顶级的动作，你知道，顶级的漫画。确实如此。所以我们有一个伊莎贝拉在聊天中提出的额外小问题，来自舒尔茨，他说，我知道一些最近听说这件事的人，并计划今年和播客一起阅读。关于分解，生活在 2024 年之后，这个前景让你感觉如何？让我感觉很好，我不知道。为什么会不好？
But so much of it is about people getting rebelling or being crushed by systems, urban infrastructure systems. And what happens when those systems are either not functioning right or when they fail outright, like when a psychic child unleashes a wave of TK force, which levels the city. But if you look to look at those from a municipal infrastructure point of view,
我不需要知道。我喜欢它作为一个资源存在。我的意思是，我觉得如果你必须为学校读这个，并想要一些陪伴，我觉得它真的可以成为一个很好的补充。而且它有罗伯特·卡罗的认可，我想他听过很多，
I think there's a lot to be found in there. And also it it's just like, it's just top notch action, you know, top notch comics. To be sure. So we have one little bonus question that Isabella has put in the chat from Schultz saying, I know a few people who heard about this whole thing recently and are planning to read along with the podcast this year. How does the prospect of the breakdown, Living Beyond 2024 make you feel? Makes me feel great, I don't know. Why would it be bad?
我认为其中有很多值得挖掘的东西。而且它确实是顶级的动作，你知道，顶级的漫画。确实如此。所以我们有一个伊莎贝拉在聊天室里提出的额外问题，来自舒尔茨，他说，我认识一些最近才听说这件事的人，他们计划今年跟着播客一起阅读。对于《崩溃：2024年之后的生活》的前景，你们感觉如何？我觉得很好，我不知道。为什么会不好呢？
I don't have to know. I like that it's there as a resource. I mean, I feel like if you had to read this for school and wanted some companionship for it, like I feel like it really could be this nice supplement that goes along with it. And it does have the imprimatur of Robert Caro who has heard many of them, I think,
我不需要知道。我喜欢它作为一个资源存在。我的意思是，我觉得如果你必须为了学校阅读这本书，并且想要一些陪伴，我觉得它真的可以成为一个很好的补充。而且它确实得到了罗伯特·卡罗的认可，我想他已经听过很多集了。
or at least he claims to have. And he thinks that our analysis is pretty good. Like he's never like bickered too much with it except for the one time that Elliot said, I think this is really funny. And he goes, that's not funny at all. That's really serious. I think it's powerful.
或者至少他声称读过。他认为我们的分析相当不错。他从来没有对此提出过太多异议，除了有一次埃利奥特说，我觉得这真的很有趣。他却说，那一点也不好笑。那是非常严肃的。我认为这很有力量。
Yeah, I was like, oh yeah, that was trouble for me. But yeah, I think it's, I love the idea that this, hopefully as a series will not disappear or evaporate, that people have it in the future. And I always thought as a writer that my legacy would be in television or in books. And I'm coming more and more around to the idea that I think my creative legacy,
是的，我当时想，哦，那对我来说是个麻烦。但我觉得，我喜欢这个想法，希望作为一个系列，它不会消失或蒸发，人们在未来还能拥有它。作为一名作家，我一直认为我的遗产将是在电视或书籍中。而我越来越倾向于认为，我的创作遗产，
if I have one, is probably going to be in podcasting. And the idea that when the 100th anniversary of the power book comes along, in theory, someone could still pick up this podcast and listen to it long while reading it. That's very, very special to me. If we can. The metaphor in my head has always been that we are like remoras, the fish that stick their heads to sharks and ride on the shark
如果我有的话，很可能是在播客领域。当《权力掮客》一百周年纪念到来时，理论上，有人仍然可以拿起这个播客，在阅读时收听它。这对我来说非常非常特别。如果我们可以的话。我脑海中的隐喻一直是，我们就像䲟鱼，那种把头贴在鲨鱼身上，骑在鲨鱼身上，
and eat what falls out of the shark's mouth. If we can stick like remoras on the fish that stick their heads to sharks and ride on the shark and eat what falls out of the shark's mouth, if we can stick like remoras on the power broker and be kind of unofficial semi-authorized and compliment to it, then that's wonderful. Yeah, I totally agree. And at some point, I think they exist in the feed there for 99% visible so we can monetize them and put ads on them. I do think at some point, I think they exist in the feed there for 99% Invisible so we can monetize them and put ads on them. I do think at some point, we will break them out on their own
吃掉从鲨鱼嘴里掉出来的东西的鱼。如果我们能像䲟鱼一样贴在《权力掮客》上，成为它非官方的、半授权的补充，那真是太棒了。是的，我完全同意。而且在某个时候，我认为它们存在于99% Invisible的订阅源中，这样我们就可以通过它们获利并投放广告。我确实认为在某个时候，我们会把它们单独拆分出来，
so that they can be sort of like found more easily and not to wade through as many 99% Invisible episodes to find them. And I do think that kids 10 years from now will find the show and hopefully find it, you know, like put it on their, and teachers will put it on their curriculums. And that'd be awesome.
这样它们可以更容易被找到，而不必为了找到它们而翻阅那么多的99% Invisible剧集。我确实认为，十年后的孩子们会发现这个节目，并希望他们能找到它，你知道，把它加入到他们的课程中，老师们也会把它加入到他们的课程中。那会很棒。
I would love that. I'm still delighted when I have six children under my care and they sometimes tell me when they get assigned a 99% visible episode and I'm always really delighted when I hear about that. And so I would love to hear that. Nobody assigns Flophouse episodes. And nobody has yet done any, you know, troll two studies
我会很喜欢那样。当我照顾的六个孩子有时告诉我他们被分配到收听一集99% Invisible时，我仍然感到很高兴，每当我听到这个消息时，我总是非常高兴。所以我很乐意听到这个。没有人会布置《Flophouse》的作业。而且还没有人做过任何，你知道，关于《巨魔2》的研究，
where they need to hear our take on it, you know. Well, that's their loss. There should be plenty of troll two studies. Yeah, people specializing in Nicholas Cage, what's the word, when it's a temporary thing, Miss Elainey, no, that's not what I'm looking for. Nevermind, I couldn't think's not what I'm looking for. Nevermind, I can't think of the word I'm thinking of.
他们需要听听我们的看法，你知道。好吧，那是他们的损失。应该有很多关于《巨魔2》的研究。是的，专门研究尼古拉斯·凯奇的人，那个词是什么来着，当它是一件临时的事情时，Miss Elainey，不，那不是我在找的。没关系，我没想到我在想的那个词。
So thanks everyone for joining us, it's been a real delight. We'll still be on the Discord, like if you wanna ask questions about the Power Broker, we'll still figure out maybe how we're gonna work together and do a similar project in the future, so we'll let you know when that happens. But in general, just catch up on the show in the feed.
所以感谢大家的加入，这真是一次愉快的经历。我们仍然会在Discord上，如果你想问关于《权力掮客》的问题，我们仍然会想办法看看未来如何合作并做类似的项目，所以当这种情况发生时我们会通知你。但总的来说，只要在订阅源里补看节目就行了。
Listen again, tell friends about it. That would be really, really fantastic. And be sure to check out the rest of Nine NPIs episodes because we talk about this stuff a lot that will interest you. So I hope that you also listen to the original recipe, Nine NPIs, because they mean a lot to me. And a lot of really, really smart people
再听一遍，告诉朋友们。那会非常非常棒。一定要看看99% Invisible的其他剧集，因为我们经常谈论这些会让你感兴趣的东西。所以我希望你也听听原汁原味的99% Invisible，因为它们对我意义重大。而且很多非常非常聪明的人，
outside of myself put those together. And also, you should listen to The Flophouse. Yeah, why not? If you want the opposite of the podcast, which is, and I don't mean, by the opposite, I don't mean me not talking very much, which is, you're not gonna get that. That is, you're just gonna get me talking too much.
除了我之外，他们一起制作了这些节目。而且，你应该听听《The Flophouse》。是的，为什么不呢？如果你想要这个播客的反面，我的意思不是，反面并不是指我不怎么说话，那是你得不到的。那只是你会得到我说话太多。
But The Flophouse podcast, the, I have been referring to it as America's first badouse podcast, I have been referring to it as America's first bad movie podcast, probably, because I'm not sure, but we're one of the first. And we're still going strong. I realized last night as I was going to sleep late from my work that in a couple years we'll be having doing it for 20 years, which is crazy. We just plan to keep doing it as long as we can. If you check out the Flophouse podcast, please do. I realize I have another podcast I can mention on the Smart List Network,
但《The Flophouse》播客，我一直称它为美国第一个烂片播客，大概吧，因为我不确定，但我们是第一批。而且我们仍然很强劲。昨晚我工作到很晚准备睡觉时意识到，再过几年我们就要做满20年了，这太疯狂了。我们只是计划尽可能长久地做下去。如果你去看看《The Flophouse》播客，请务必去看看。我意识到我还有另一个播客可以在Smart List Network上提到，
which is called Clueless, which is like a 10-12 minute puzzle podcast where I ask the questions and Sean Hayes answers the questions. It's really good. I like it a lot. Thank you. It's a fun one to do. We're recording more tomorrow, which means I have to write some more.
它叫《Clueless》，这是一个10到12分钟的益智播客，我问问题，肖恩·海耶斯回答问题。它真的很好。我很喜欢。谢谢。这是一个很有趣的节目。我们明天还要录制更多，这意味着我必须再写一些。
I currently have a series coming out from DC Comics. It's the Harley Quinn book. That's right, Harley Quinn, America's favorite kind of anarchic lady clown. I'm writing her book for, I guess, the foreseeable future. And I've managed to make this the first kind of 12 issues that I'm working on of it mostly about gentrification like her trying to stop a developer from changing the last, from getting rid of the last block of her old neighborhood that reminds her of her own neighborhood. So her older sister, I'm like,
我目前正在DC漫画公司推出一个系列。是《哈莉·奎茵》的书。没错，哈莉·奎茵，美国最受欢迎的那种无政府主义女士小丑。我想在可预见的未来，我都会写她的书。而且我设法让我正在创作的前12期内容主要关于士绅化，比如她试图阻止开发商改变她旧社区的最后一块街区，这让她想起了她自己的社区。所以她的大姐姐，我像，
I'm like, oh, I managed to get a little bit of, like kind of power broker adjacent into the Harley Quinn comic book. I'm very excited about this. You should lift a whole scene from the power broker. Put it in the middle of it. I should just start putting, I should just start putting quotes,
我像，哦，我设法在《哈莉·奎茵》漫画书中加入了一点点《权力掮客》相关的内容。我对此感到非常兴奋。你应该从《权力掮客》中摘取整段场景。把它放在中间。我应该开始放，我应该开始放引语，
like the words from Marlowe's in the mouth of it. I should just start putting, I should just start putting like words from Marlowe's in the mouth of the villain character. So that's on Confook Store shelves, once a month is Harley Quinn. Awesome, well thank you again everyone for being part of this project with us and thank you Elliot so much. It's just been just such a fun year.
比如把马洛的话放在反派角色的嘴里。所以这就是在漫画书店的货架上，每月一期的《哈莉·奎茵》。太棒了，再次感谢大家参与我们的这个项目，也非常感谢埃利奥特。这真是非常有趣的一年。
I've loved working with you. I've been admiring your work for a very long time. We've been friends that didn't really hang out very much for a very long time. We talked a lot about making plans to hang out. Exactly. It never kind of came together. And so I'm so glad that we had this opportunity
我很喜欢和你一起工作。我钦佩你的工作已经很长时间了。我们是朋友，但很长一段时间都没有真正聚在一起。我们谈了很多关于聚会的计划。没错。从来没有真正实现过。所以我很高兴我们有这个机会，
to get together at least once a month to talk about something we both really care about. So thank you, everybody, and thanks for listening. It's been really a blast. Thank you, everybody, and thanks for listening. It's been really a blast. Thank you so much. This bonus episode of the 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker was produced by Isabel Angel, edited by Comiti, music by Swan Real, mixed by Martin Gonzalez.
至少每月聚一次，谈论我们都非常关心的事情。所以谢谢大家，感谢收听。这真是一次很棒的经历。谢谢大家，感谢收听。这真是一次很棒的经历。非常感谢。这集99% Invisible《权力掮客》解析的特别节目由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔制作，科米蒂剪辑，天鹅真实音乐，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。
Make sure you get your Power Broker Breakdown merch. There's the Robert Moses Band t-shirt with all the dates of the episodes and chapters on the back, so you never forget how much you read in 2024. We've got a great sturdy tote bag that you can carry any of the books that we recommended today. At the time of this recording, the Power Broker Challenge coins are in stock. We also got some great merch that's just branded to 99% Invisible. It's all really good stuff. It's all at 99pi.org slash store. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy, too. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director. The rest of the team
确保你买到了《权力掮客》解析的周边商品。有罗伯特·摩西乐队的T恤，背面印有所有剧集和章节的日期，这样你就永远不会忘记你在2024年读了多少。我们有一个很棒的结实手提袋，你可以装下我们今天推荐的任何书籍。在录制此节目时，权力掮客挑战币有现货。我们还有一些很棒的99% Invisible品牌周边。所有东西都很棒。都在99pi.org/store。99% Invisible的执行制片人是凯西·图。我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔。库尔特·科尔斯特是数字总监。团队的其他成员，
includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Jacob Medina Gleason, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find me on the show on Blue Sky and on our Discord server. We have a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI. And please download many, many episodes of 99PI. Please, it would mean a lot. You can find them at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·雷、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格，还有我，罗曼·马斯。99% Invisible的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。该系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区，向北六个街区处的潘多拉大楼。你可以在Blue Sky和我们的Discord服务器上找到我。我们有相关链接，以及99PI的每一集往期节目。请下载许多许多集的99PI。拜托，这对我意义重大。你可以在99PI.org找到它们。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。